de la frialdad en Ucrania a la calidez
en Rusia
así avanzó la misión de paz encabezada
por varios líderes del continente
africano a pesar del ambiente distendido
el mensaje fue claro
este es el momento para que ambas partes
negocien para negociar el fin de esta
guerra porque esta guerra está causando
una gran inestabilidad y daños a varios
países del Mundo
la reunión se desarrolló en San
Petersburgo en el contexto del foro
económico Internacional del que Putin es
asiduo se trataron varios temas
similares a los abordados en kiev en
especial las afectaciones que sufren los
niños ucranianos por la invasión
los niños que han quedado atrapados en
este conflicto deben ser devueltos a su
lugar de origen a sus hogares
por su parte el presidente ruso no dio
señales de avance a la misión de paz
dirigiendo la culpa a la actitud de kiev
por falta de garantías el proyecto de
este acuerdo fue firmado por el jefe del
grupo de negociaciones de kiev lo firmó
aquí lo tienes
pero después de que como prometimos
retiramos nuestras propias de kiev las
autoridades como suelen hacer sus dueños
lo tiraron todo por la basura mucha
historia trato de ser Cortés lo
rechazaron
en la víspera también dejó Clara su
posición
quiero reiterar que necesitamos una paz
real y por lo tanto una retirada real de
las tropas rusas de toda nuestra tierra
independiente
estos esfuerzos de paz se llevan a cabo
en medio de la contraofensiva que
desarrolló Ucrania para retomar
territorios ocupados y por el momento no
parecen dar resultados